[Music]
if it weren't for the Trot there would
be complete
silence even animals here have gone
quiet hindii which Armenians called
stanaker has been deserted nearly
everyone is gone after ethnic Armenian
leaders agreed with aeran that the
so-call state of artah will cease to
exist and it feels everyone just got up
and left
strewn with whatever people couldn't
carry with them the Town Center where
thousands had gathered now paints an
unreal Eerie
scene the morg staff left too so even
the dead are being repatriated to
Armenia by the Red Cross we count to
keep on finding other uh people still
stranded for the time being in the city
in the
outskirts uh and therefore we have
another concern considering the rural
areas haven't been reached yet the
streets are completely empty all that
you can see here are a scattered few
checkpoints on the entrance of H keni
Russian peacekeepers inside and maybe a
few soldiers here we've got the last
remaining ethnic
Armenians gathering at a staging point
for those who still want to
leave he says this is our
city also a place place where those who
are staying say
goodbye this ethnic Armenian man hugged
the first aarani he
saw he says I want to live here with
everyone I have aarani friends who tell
me I shouldn't leave so I am staying
here the administration says it started
a registration Center provided
ambulances revamped mobile networks and
connected the city to the electric grid
but the few people Left Behind still
need urgent
care if you asked me about the immediate
needs uh it's certainly uh to uh
consider yeah Power gas for the winter
coming and water now for the outskirts
and the other regions for sure uh we
have been here for decades and uh we
look forward to work with the aeran
authorities we are actually we have all
has been in contact with
[Music]
them and in order to have a
future this city will need
humans to refill its empty
streets
soj heni
aan make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from
aler